- [Instructor] Now we're
gonna talk about an important
Supreme Court case that
reinforced the idea
that states have to
provide the same rights
when people are arrested
and accused of a crime,
as are guaranteed in the
United States Constitution.
And that case is Gideon versus Wainwright.
So in 1961, you have a
gentleman by the name of
Clarence Earl Gideon, who's in a pool hall
and he's accused of stealing some beer
and soda and about $50.
And there's one witness
who said that they saw
Clarence Gideon walking
away with some soda and beer
in his pockets and some
change in his pockets.
Now when he gets arrested
and he goes to court,
he wants to have access to counsel,
he can't afford a lawyer by himself.
But Florida, at the time,
did not give everyone access to a lawyer.
That was only in capital offenses
or in certain other cases.
So Clarence Earl Gideon
had to defend himself
and he loses the case and he gets
the maximum sentence of five years.
Now while he is in prison,
he begins to study the law
and the Constitution in particular.
And he reads things like
the Sixth Amendment,
which say in all criminal prosecutions,
the accused shall enjoy the right to
a speedy and public trial, by
an impartial jury of the state
and district wherein the crime
shall have been committed,
which district shall have been
previously ascertained by law,
and to be informed of the nature
and cause of the accusation,
to be confronted with
the witness against him,
to have compulsory process for
obtaining witnesses in his favor,
and to have the assistance
of counsel for his defense.
So he's saying hey, this is
here in the Constitution.
It's the Sixth Amendment
saying that I need to have
assistance of counsel for my defense.
And he studies section
one of the 14th Amendment.
All persons born or naturalized
in the United States
and subject to the jurisdiction thereof,
are citizens of the United States
and of the state wherein they reside.
No state shall make or
enforce any law which shall
abridge the privileges
or immunities of citizens
of the United States, nor
shall any state deprive any
person of life, liberty, or property,
without due process of law,
nor deny to any person within
its jurisdiction the equal
protection of the laws.
We'll he's saying here, look,
the Sixth Amendment says
that I have a right to
assistance of counsel,
essentially to have a lawyer
that the state needs to provide.
And the Constitution makes
it very clear that no state
can make or enforce a law
which abridges my privileges
that they can't deprive
me of life, liberty,
or property without
the due process of law.
And part of that due process is to have
access to counsel for defense.
And so he petitions
first the Florida courts
and they keep rejecting him.
But eventually he writes to the
United States Supreme Court.
And in 1962 the United
States Supreme Court
decides to take Clarence
Earl Gideon's case.
And not only do they take his case,
they provide a lawyer for him.
And the lawyer is able to get
a nine zero verdict in
Clarence Gideon's favor.
And so that did not
acquit him of the crime,
but it says that he
has a right to counsel.
So back in Florida, he gets a retrial.
And in that retrial, he has a lawyer
and that lawyer is able to
question that one witness
in depth that says that
Clarence was walking away
with soda and beer and
change in his pockets
and create a substantial amount of doubt.
And then the jury, after
only an hour of deliberation,
says no, it hasn't been
proven that Clarence Gideon
is guilty beyond a reasonable doubt.
And he is free.
So this is an amazing case.
One it's amazing that an
individual sitting in jail
could learn about the Constitution
and petition the US Supreme Court
and win that case that
ensures that all 50 states
have to provide legal
counsel for the accused.